[Music]
[Applause]
you can't go out
there traffic is building rapidly
downtown as Citizens rush to get home
before commencement if you're not
purging we advise you to get off the
streets as quickly as possible it'll
soon be a war out there this is your
emergency broadcast system announcing
the commencement of the annual Purge at
the siren all crime including murder
will be legal for 12 hours all emergency
services will be
suspended your government thanks you for
your
participation please just let us
[Music]
Purge just remember all good The Purge
does what is
this
People Like Us don't survive
[Music]
tonight this is the last Purge of the AG
this night saved our country the bidding
will start at
200,000
[Music]
n